is one of our favorite guests to have on
the show and I'm gonna stop talking like
he's not here good to see you Billie
guard thanks for having me back you bet
so let's let's just get right into it go
ahead let's go jive just dive right into
the deep end of the pool okay god what
is it like for a die-hard Pittsburgh guy
to see Philadelphia being termed as a
city of Champions which you cannot argue
with with them I do not argue in fact
I'm excited about it for him but let's
let's put that in perspective you know
one Super Bowl trophy takes up a case
about that big six trophy case about dad
babe it's much more I mean it's it's a
yearly moniker they earned it they
brought a lot of joy into my house and
they hit the over which was very
exciting I rooted for them and I it was
funny because the the rivalry for
Pittsburgh Philly is not football people
mistake that it's hockey and by the way
the Pens are in looking for a three-peat
we believe and my Bucs are undefeated
right now I'll take it I'll take it I
know but people were like asking me are
you gonna root for Philadelphia of
course I was gonna root for Philadelphia
because I think my my disdain for New
England is well-documented and we had
that issue at Christmas you know yeah we
were strolling around New York you lit a
candle Jets to try and beat the Patriots
just like a Dickens novel walking around
waiting for the next ghost to visit me
but I'm fill it when people asked me if
I was gonna root for Philly I was like
yeah and they were surprised and they're
like well how can you do that and I was
like well one I don't like New England
and outside of Boston and some
transplants I don't know who was rooting
for New England I think everybody was
written for Philly and just the story of
that team was good but the Steelers we
kind of look at Philly like you know
that cousin in your family that gets a
lot of duis and he's in trouble and then
they do something good so then you got
to show up at the thing and support them
that's kind of how we felt we showed
some the troubled cousin you know yeah I
was kind of waiting for the back of the
hand yeah you know you extended your
hand well you
gracefully the back out front for man it
was nice to see Brady sitting on his can
at the end of the game mm-hmm and
showing the true sportsman that he was
by not shaking hands and running off the
field it's you guys you haven't done
well enough Tom you're right you
shouldn't so sit down and pout so you
had gave me great joy you rooted for
filly hard and I did why absolutely
absolutely yeah no question all right
that'd be a Billy Gardell here on the
Rich Eisen show so all that said it's
incredible how you were concerned about
home-field advantage
for an AFC Championship game yeah that
never materialized no it didn't well in
fact what an embarrassment
you know I Jacksonville was a good team
but they weren't that good and when you
throw up 40 and change in the playoffs
and lose you got to really look at the
holes in the defense and I you know
losing shazier to that awful injury God
had way more of an impact than anybody
realized the whole year that whole year
you had trouble with the flats and
anybody who could work that on us really
expose that and Jacksonville did that
they went up and down net the the the
field with these little wing outs 5-7
yards Brady murders us with it and and
we're just really susceptible to it and
when shazier went down we were really
susceptible to it our defense has always
been predicated since really the cour
generation where we have really vicious
pass rushers on the line and then the
line backing core and that kind of hides
the holes in the secondary and losing
him and with a couple guys not turning
out the way they should have I think
that was really exposed the secondary
was so terrible this year that it was
just it was just dismal to watch and
well I'm pretty sure our safeties and
cornerbacks knew the last name of every
wide receiver in the league because they
spent the whole year chasing them so it
was and that's what I think we need to
address and so what do you think the
dealers need to do okay let's let's say
a couple things here levy on bill tweets
out that it's tough to be a hero in a
city that paints you is
villain there now I I think I think
that's a little dramatic I think you
know Pittsburgh is a very working-class
city so when you ask for a lot of money
you're gonna get knocked around a little
bit and Antonio Brown got his contract
and he waited and got his contract and
that's what'll happen with levian if
he's patient
but once and while you're gonna get the
tag slapped on you and we sat with you
through two blown knees so you know what
man you got you got to do what you're
told and you got it you got to get your
money and I understand that but rules
are the rules and you know look man if
you don't like it go to Miami I don't
care you know I'm pretty hard lined with
blue two knees out and we waited for you
to come back okay and that's okay
all right that's part of it but
understand that this is just a business
it's not personal they're gonna they're
gonna tag you when they can and they're
not when they can so you know I look I
wish him luck I hope he gets his money I
just hope he's at camp at the beginning
of the season or it's gonna be then he
will be a villain and it'll be hard to
come back Billy Gardell you're in the
Rich Eisen show do you think the
Pittsburgh treats everything like an old
car we're bad about that like now you
bleep tires I'm gonna wait and see how
it's running for I give them another
contract you know I mean you gotta you
gotta play the play so do you what do
you think the Steelers should do in the
first round is if Lamar Jackson sitting
in there I grab them grab them with both
hands you do I would and I like I tell
you um I think what we need to address
is we need a really good linebacker a
guy that can come in and make an impact
right away
the secondary we're missing that we're
missing that guy that gives us half the
field like Paul amol you did Cornell
Lake did we need a guy that shuts down
an area we haven't had that for years
and then I think there's I really like a
quarterback a little bit maybe in the
second or third round I like there's a
big horse of a kid in Oklahoma kind of
reminds me of Big Ben and I think he
would be maybe a good investment for the
future they did from Oklahoma State yeah
big kid and I think he could he's got a
rifle arm and I think he would fit our
system very well and it maybe Ben Mason
Rudolph that's it Mason so I think that
Ben could tutor him I think
be a good choice for the fear do you
think Ben has got the mr. chips in him
I think he's gonna if they go ahead and
get some kid yeah you think he would
take a person like brownie and get him
traded to San Francisco Big Ben Big Ben
has we could do we could do a nice dr.
Melfi on him sure question yeah cuz he's
quit and he's not quitting he's far he's
proud he's pulling too far from when you
start talking about that then it's time
to bring a kid in just to be ready you
know what I mean so when you do want to
go you go and Josh Dobbs there too you
know I don't know what he's gonna be I
don't know I'd love for him to turn out
great he see I don't know if he's gonna
fit our system good the guy's a rocket
scientist so I'm sure he but I don't
know if he's gonna be our guy I don't
know we'll see I like I said that's
that's a big if I think Ben's gonna come
back as long as that offense is intact I
mean why would you leave when you have
levy on bail and you have Antonio Brown
and you have some of these you know juju
these other guys coming up and and
starting to spark the offense all those
pieces are in place but you got to be
able to play football not have to score
40 points again to win Billy Gardell
here in the Rich Eisen show we'll take a
60-second break come back and play a
little start bench college yeah man all
right we'll do that
Chris Brockman is only half an hour to
go in clown makeup thank goodness no we
also have a rising overtime segment you
know saw as an extra so you have about
about 35 minutes to go
that's Chris Brockman in the clown
makeup Billy Gardell to my right back
with you here in 60 seconds
all right Billy Gardell hanging out with
us during the draft that we're talking
about yes she's gonna be in Syracuse New
York how do you know this tour dates
awesome I will be in Syracuse New York
funny bone so a year so you'll be maybe
traveling during the the first night of
the draft yeah Friday through Sunday I
know I'm an old-fashioned guy still
enjoy the newspaper the day after and I
kind of make my little charts for the
yellow tablet and okay I like yellow
tablet I like to look it over well for
us who are hosting a televised version
of the draft you know we'd like you to
come to the 21st century why I'm not a
fan i watch when I can but I like to
read the paper the next day and read
good look at you
all right a funny bone in Syracuse New
York on my new hour I've got to go to
dinosaur barbecue Billy okay
dinosaur barbecue downtown right on I
have never passed up a barbecue
recognize sadly that's why I look like I
do and then May 25th and 26th you'll be
in New Buffalo Michigan at the Four
Winds Casino Resort and an Atlantic City
at the beautiful Borgata one of my
favorite places to play and my friend
Michael Symon has a restaurant down
there Angeline which is just great
Italian food so and they got a sports
book and there's some horses at run rich
is it true that in in both and I turned
to my degenerate in the clown makeup I
love well that is it true that in the to
Villanova runs two championships yes two
years yes sure that the friends
situation is we like to call it the the
Villanova Wildcats if you will
covered these friends each and every
time that a true story were 12 and Oh in
the two championship runs as we like to
say rich against the spread Wow I
tweeted out a write for that when I was
betting with my heart last night oh you
bet with your heart Wow I got you and
then I got a pot my good
Matt Nelson is a writer and he's a big
Michigan guy too and so yeah again I'm
sucked into the emotion of it I'm a
National Football League employee sir I
turn it to unsolder cake man for fun oh
look at you it was wagering just for fun
for dinner okay
yeah nice wakin enough twelve oh no
that's unbelievable twelve oh no against
the spread and the two championship runs
wow they look monstrous man and the
thing that was scary about them is I
watched them I went to Vegas for a part
for the opening weekend and it just
seems like anybody on that team can take
over at any time yeah that's and then
the rest of them supported which if the
lights out that helps really really hard
yeah I mean as that they have four guys
if not all five guys who can shoot from
anywhere on the floor and reach and if
they're if they're not lumbering then
they're gonna be able to move without
the ball move with the ball break down a
defense and if look if anybody could
shoot a three yeah and anybody can break
down a defense that's it that's it we
might they remind me of the Spurs when
the Spurs went on that run it's that
same kind of just playing fundamental
and then shooting assassin shots
whenever they needed it and just quietly
up and down up and down up and down up
and down Billy Gardell here on the on
the Rich Eisen show okay we've got some
start bench cuts for you here all right
let's do a put people into certain
predicaments so because I know you do
I'm familiar with the show rich you have
to start one you got a bench one you
must cut one all right Billy Gardell
you cut the music please for my billy
goat don't Pittsburgh sports icon Mario
Lemieux Chuck Noll pop star gel okay Wow
Wow I got a cut one of them now notice
we just we took Clemente out of it you
guys just ripped my heart out right
there okay um I'm gonna cut Mario Wow
and I love him I love him he only saved
the damn team I love him know I love him
and I respect him but in in sports
favorites for me I'm a football fan of
baseball friend than a hockey fan got
you and it's
1/2 again so I got a cup Mario mmm I'm
gonna bench null because Willie Stargell
was my idol when I was playing baseball
at 9 and 10 I used to do I had a bat
bigger than I should have and I did the
whirlwind wind-up and I loved Willie
Stargell because of his that was my team
when I was a kid 79 pirates the lumber
company we are family
and he always Timmy Stargell just looked
like somebody's dad who got off work and
and drove did a ballpark to play first
base like he wasn't this ripped up guy
and yet he could hit a ton and and he
was he was the heartbeat of that team so
I'm gonna start starting were you
missing up right there because you're
talking about major Pittsburgh icons but
Willie Stargell was very special plus I
used to listen to Bob Prince call the
pirate games with my grandmother on the
back porch and he would always say
chicken on the hill with will and we had
him all the way and Stargell was always
the middle of that so he's very special
yeah first thing I did when I made some
money was get some autograph Willie
Stargell stuff like on one pad got a
baseball I got a rookie card signed and
I have a I have a 8 by 10 of him you
know that the old eight by tens each tab
where they're on their knee
yeah holding the bass you're gonna have
that autographed and he pops with my
house my that's my god there you go all
right
next start bench cut for Billy Gardell
greatest quarterback from Western PA oh
we have chosen those with trophies okay
all right Joe Namath Joe Montana Johnny
Unitas well I'm gonna bench Unitas
because his knees and his hands actually
they was named its knees so we're gonna
cut Namath look man these are hard
decisions all right it's not easy to be
a GM okay and I got to start Montana cuz
he don't like Joe cool man you're too
small you're too skinny you're never
gonna make it in the NFL and that's
that's music to Pennsylvanians ears oh I
can't is that right let me take my rings
off at night plink plink plink
plink you know and it's amazing at the
combine every year yeah the 40-yard dash
line right is honcho if you will by an
old-school Pittsburgh Steeler scout
named Mark Gore says that right
who was joe Montana's Center in high
school that's awesome cannot no more
Western PA not mine and all that stuff
Montana to me was you know you're not
supposed to be able to do it that that
carries to anything you do in the sight
I was not supposed to be a 300-pound man
who became a romantic lead so don't tell
us we can't do it that's all I'm saying
so that's why Joe gets to start all
right another start bench cut for Billy
good I love that can I stay on for like
two hours you may do so absolutely
here we go best Stadium in which to take
in a game Heinz Field okay
PNC Park or the old Civic Arena Billy
Gordon the Civic Arena while it was
there when I was a kid I saw my first
rock concert at the Civic Arena Billy
Joel hey and I think there were still I
think we had cigarette butt burns on the
floor there right up until they tore two
joint down but we'll have to have to cut
the igloo because that would lose you
know man
my Steelers are my love so I got a star
start in Heinz I guess star Heinz and
then our bench PNC but but they're right
there they're ready to go like they're a
phone call away because it's one of the
most beautiful places to watch a
baseball game I think in the country and
I've been to a bunch of them that's
really spectacular not just being a
homer
that's a beautiful Edina and I'm not
just saying it because of you but coming
out of that Fort Pitt tunnel the best
when debugging a hole when it's like
like Gotham City is right in there
that's an e we do it at night there's
really nothing like seeing that city and
I love that Heinz and PNC are right next
to each other they're both off and lit
at the same time there it is beautiful
all right last one last star bench cut
for Billy going we ask this of all of
our guests best movie The Fugitive
Shawshank Redemption
well you've got mail we're having dinner
with the wife you know I don't know or
if you're homesick at college and going
to the movie that's a mom or college
movie right walking through the house
and I hear the dialogue okay so III
bench that and again it's a phone call
away we could get them up and working
Jenny yeah yeah we got a start Shawshank
because that's an epic classic movie and
honestly I would listen to Morgan
Freeman read the phone book yeah by the
way I love asking that question out of
context in context Chris Brockman he
would you cut the fugitive and yeah
benched Shawshank and started you've got
mail you started you've got you dress
like a clown it's because my freshman
year of college
oh you know having a bat my mom came to
visit me unprompted on a weekend and we
went and saw that movie in the theater
so it kind of holds a little place in my
heart you know I'm uh you know loved my
mom
that's weak weak shout-out to the moms
don't tell nobody about that and keep it
like a secret I got
boozled aforementioned Sarah T honest I
like her even more she sold me out all
right check out Billy Gardell when he's
coming through your town next towns in
Syracuse New York in late April late May
New Buffalo Michigan Atlantic City New
Jersey I follow him on Twitter you
should too at Billy Gardell also I'm a
guest starring on young Sheldon so check
out young Sheldon fantastic yeah yeah so
that's so fun for my old boss Chuck
Lorre it's it's unfortunate that that
guy Chuck Lorre is only times still we
pet and great to see you thank you for
having me Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience